hello there reject nation we are going
to watch today a video that when it came
out can't tell you how many tweets
instagram messages and even during our
venom let the recon and spoiler talk how
many people were just coming in saying
we gotta watch this video andrew
garfield's spider-man is real vfx
artists explain why those vfxrs being
the corridor crew there's anyone to
trust it is the professionals themselves
they're watching watching corridor crew
video at least on camera seen a bunch
it wasn't recorded reaction or anything
let's see what they have to say
[Music]
so what you see here is a clip that was
apparently leaked
we're going to break down the video
pixel by pixel to determine its
is it possible that the shot was faked
or is it real
all right see what they got to say
nothing gets fans more excited than
crossovers the avengers
wandaverse when the guy who played
quicksilver played quicksilver but he
was from the other franchise what
dude the spiderburst movies what
we're doing in live action now
multiverse is a concept about which we
now frighteningly
i'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
so you see here is a clip that was
apparently leaked obviously showing
andrew garfield on set as his character
from the amazing spider-man series it's
weird when a video clip like this comes
out it's very clearly andrew garfield
yet he turns around and says no it is
not i
i heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop photoshop who do
you believe here's what people are
saying online about this it's been
revealed that andrew garfield's
appearance in the latest spider-man
movie was in fact a deep fake the
hollywood star who played the
web-slinging superhero in the last movie
will not be reprising his role after
producers discovered he had been
replaced by an a.i trained to
impersonate yeah
you're having a difficult time with
andrew garfield he couldn't get him to
come sometimes filming would be delayed
because of his commitments to some movie
about quadriplegic single mother anyways
anyways the article goes on but it
proves the point that this video of
andrew garfield is fake
that article is fake sam literally
generated it with an ai much like the
actual articles oh god that's hilarious
they had me going because i was like
when did john what say to you that i
know i could have heard about that that
would have been all over the news it
really was messing with him like the
only thing to talk about with that john
watch was explicitly stating that he
they tried getting him and they couldn't
and yeah i mean i've heard that theory
too that like what if they andrew
garfield they had his likeness and were
able to de-fake him on there i've heard
that discussion kind of go around too
but anyway let's continue this video man
because it's already shaped up to be
pretty fun articles written about this
subject that seem to be written by
ai so sam and i are going to cut through
that conflicting information today we're
going to break down the video pixel by
pixel to determine its authenticity is
it possible that the shot was faked or
is it real so come with us through the
critical thinking process so next time
something like this happens you can
figure it out for yourself
yeah i think i'll still rely on you
this is an actual cinema camera or a
rather high quality camera it's a large
sensor because you can see some depth of
field here this isn't like some person
on their phone either it's like some
ripped footage from a behind-the-scenes
crew or someone who has like tapped into
one of the actual
monitors on set this could just be
footage from when he was filming
spider-man and he's just talking to a
stunt double like do you want me to
stand like you were standing like this
all right so if we compare that footage
with the original footage from the hair
using spiderman yeah there's a pretty
big difference between the two his
hairdo is different he looks a lot
younger he looks like he's in high
school but main thing is his hair dude
like they wouldn't just have a different
hairdo for one day on set here so this
most likely this new footage
his face looks like it's a different
resolution from his costume slightly
blurrier there does seem to be a slight
lack of detail there it's a bit of an
anomaly in my opinion because if we're
looking at like the bars there we can
see like surface imperfections on the
beams and it does seem like there's a
slight lack of quality on the face that
being said like generally if you upload
a video to a social media platform the
chances that it's going to be a mp4 file
it's it's pretty likely and the way mp4
files work is by compressing
motion
into an overall image so it's less about
rendering an unique frame every single
frame but taking
one frame and then basically saying all
right this is the direction the pixels
are moving so that way we have motion
data instead of image data it's called
iframes and keyframes so an example like
this oh like 1080i and 1080p clip
everything that's not moving is going to
stay
crisp while the things moving will have
less
hell of this phenomenon
is that we are in fact looking at a deep
fake of andrew garfield i don't think
this is a deep fake this would be the
best defect i've ever seen if it's a
deep fake 100 percent i mean the best
defense i've ever seen is the tom cruise
deep fakes those are so organic
oh yes oh
so candy i mean those are wonderful but
you can tell the deep fix if you
scrutinize it you can see there's no
crisp shadow under the nose from the
sunlight there's a bit of a sense of
like his face is being lit and then like
re-lit again
i feel
uh
still
comfortable there's a button
but even like the teeth like the
lighting on the teeth is not quite right
also you can see it feels a little bit
like it's a flat texture of a face you
know as opposed to like a
three-dimensional object so that's
because the computer is trained on a
bunch of images of a face well those
images are filmed at all different focal
lengths and oftentimes if you're doing
say you know training from movies like
let's say we're doing a tom cruise deep
fake and you're grabbing all these tom
cruise shots so a lot of times you're
using close-ups close-ups are often shot
with a telephoto lens and what a
telephoto lens does is it tends to
flatten everything so my face has a lot
of distortion right my nose is scaled up
a little bit because it's closer to you
my ears my face is probably kind of like
a little fish-eyed and these get a
little bit smaller get perspective on my
face
now you kind of see how everything's
flattened on my face and you've probably
seen like the gifs of this on reddit or
something like that like look at what
lenses do to the face what ends up
happening is that when you put a deep
dick on the face you kind of get this
weird like flat nose effect or like the
whole face is almost like this like
squished lack of perspective
in real life should actually be getting
a lot more perspective and depth and
almost like vanishing points
representing themselves on the face as
the geometry moves around it's really
really
good but just scrutinize it it's not
quite right that mind let's go back to
andrew garfield i feel like with like
deep fakes a lot of the time it can also
come down to just kind of this
subconscious feeling
where you can just sort of tell
yeah even if you don't know how to even
put it into words because these guys are
quite articulate and they're well
crafted and educated in this field the
visual effects so they know all the
proper language and lingo to communicate
it thoroughly unlike people such as
genre ourselves yet though even as
people who are not experts in this field
whatsoever you could still get that
feeling there's just something in the
subconscious of your eyes it's like the
way how you could tell something is
visual effects no matter how good it is
you can still tell it's probably cgi
it's like it's rare where you're
completely fooled it's the tribute to
how well the human eye and mind can
process little things like body language
and little things like yeah how the
light is supposed to hit a face it
really gives you kind of an appreciation
for all that stuff in the subconscious
that helps you comprehend and suss out
things like that the first thing i'm
seeing is there's an edge light coming
from the top right corner kind of a
bluish daylight blue edge light it's
hitting the the lines on his costume
it's also hitting the side of his neck
at the corner of his jaw and his hair
here
a little bit of the corner of the jaw
catching the light is interesting
because that specific kind of sharp
lighting detail that's something a deep
fake does not do very well most deep
fakes cover this part of the face you
can do whole head deep fakes but they
get blurry and low resolution so that
would mean that the hair has to be real
he almost never deep fake hair it's very
very hard to do especially especially
such bountiful hair like that
another thing to look at is the eyes so
your eyes are reflective they're spheres
the reflections in both eyes should be
consistent with each other if one eye
shows one light reflection the other eye
shows two light reflections well then
that's a sign that the eyes are being
faked
the bright spots looking at his eyes i
see consistent reflections in both
another thing i'm seeing the sharpness
of the shadows going off of his nose on
the side of his face and more
importantly into his mouth you can see
the glistening light on the water of his
tongue and it's consistent the deep fake
might catch that here and there but it
has no idea of what's causing highlights
or light it just knows statistically
where these things go no edge your car
feels totally in this room
specific trained data of andrew
garfield's tongue with light glistening
on it at the correct color type return
angle to be able to replicate it here i
mean if the andrew garfield shot is a
deep fake maybe somebody's just thought
it'd be a funny joke to to fake this i
mean there are good deep fake artists
out there that could theoretically move
like this yeah well as real as this
looks
it has been revealed that this shot
is a deep fade
[Music]
yeah right
i can already tell this is fake the
puppet
[Laughter]
no but look they depict it see how the
track the lips and the nose and the eyes
are being tracked all right alex serrato
is trying to track it with itself said
as much on his youtube channel what alex
serrano did because he was like thank
you guys you made my point here i
trolled everyone i trolled everyone see
and his video was about trolling i don't
know what his overall sinister plan was
but one thing he has done is he has made
himself quite infamous he's the sixth
member of the sinister city kind of
clever what he's done now he's even been
shouted out in a quarter in that video
was huge now people will be keeping an
eye on that channel alex serrano the
most notorious name on youtube regarding
spider-man these days all right so the
big giveaway here for me is this deep
fake training grid so when you have this
grid view one set of faces is the face
that's going to be put on the other
person the other set of faces is the
person who will be receiving the face in
other words this shouldn't all be andrew
garfield one row should be
the other row should be the actor
that's that's the funny thing he's
training his deep fake on the final
image
yeah
yeah so where's the other actor because
you don't just like it doesn't generate
a face from nothing that's i think it's
really funny i love that alex did this
but i think that the number of news
articles that we're not saying it turns
out oh it turns out it was a deep fake
after all and they just point to this
it's like all they had to do was show
the training shot to one person who's
ever done a dpic in their life and they
would immediately know it's not real
there is one thing about this that
caught me like
when he enhances the face
and it's the way his teeth jump around
when it's enhanced here so what's
happening here is he's using an ai up
resin algorithm here that's looking at
the face and it's analyzing detail and
filling in extra detail
and so the reason the wrinkles are
moving on the lips or the way the teeth
the heights are shifting is it's
identifying patterns and it's guessing
yeah maybe this is the top of the tooth
and then a few frames later it goes no
this is the top of the tooth and so the
tooth constantly jumps around all the
details are not temporally consistent as
we would say now in a real deep fake
this is something you would actually run
into you would run into the teeth
shimmying around a little bit you run
into the wrinkles on the lips shimming
around a little bit
all right so this video is fake but are
there any other ways one could fake this
video without using a deep fake this
could be andrew garfield cut out from a
film and they set up the shot to like
look like it that's how i would fake it
like i would find a shot of andrew
garfield where i can match the lighting
and like the motions and i just cut it
out and stick it onto my footage you can
get pretty close i mean here's the thing
at the end of the day could this be
faked yes this could be faked it would
be
very very very very very good fakery
i don't think it's a deep fake deep fix
are not magic they're really not that
crazy they require a ton of artistry to
actually blend and look real also it's
probably not even a leak like at this
point if i was a movie studio what's
gonna get more pressed like an actual
official photo that's released or a
leaked one you're telling me i'm not
supposed to see this
it's like i'm totally clicking on that
yeah i mean they just got us to talk
about this for a whole video look at
that right
hashtag
ad
question
is this an ad if we just oh crap
spider-man damn dude so this video was
brought to you by disney and spider-man
and we even have a special additional
clip for you guys to check out of the
film here it
is everyone's got super powers
well everyone but me
yes
spiderman that was like a movie idea
yeah great superhero i love the original
movies with toby maguire all the
spider-man movies they're super fun and
would it be exciting to see one where
all the cast members from different
films come together for a single hit uh
yeah it would be super cool thanks for
watching everybody really appreciate it
i'd love some more clips you know
like real footage real footage ghost
footage the bigfoot footage point us to
some very specific shots that you want
to see us take a look at to see if we
can spot any residual artifacts of
visual effects artistry or you can try
to figure out they are exactly 100 real
we'll find your mysteries and we'll
solve them
figure out if they swapped out toby for
tom in the straighter hey look it's not
spiderman
let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man they do leave it out in the open
that it's a possibility could be faked
but i feel like at this point if it was
fake that person would come clean and
that person would have every job
opportunity available in the vfx you
know you'd have an incredible you'd be
like that criminal who was caught yeah
and they'd be like i want you to come
work for me now yeah you do our whole
cyber security operation no one's ever
been able to break into my vault before
yeah
oh man that was great all right guys
well leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell please
subscribe to corridor crew if you
haven't done so already they are the g's
anyway let's do it
pandemic jones i want to see you deep
faked right into this spider-man movie
as well think about it you could be ned
you could be the guy in the chair
pandemic jones all of the world laid at
your feet with your best friend
spider-man but oh no look out what is
there a rift coming are you gonna become
the hobgoblin
pandemic
oh the possibilities of the multiverse
are at your fingertips but the best
possibility
i can think of was seeing you earlier of
the day of filming this shout out in our
venom let there be carnage spoiler live
stream just always makes me happy to see
how much love and support you're willing
to throw away spending hours on the
internet just listen to us riff on
movies
love you buddy
and stay pledged
okay